how to sell radio and magazine ads so I
got a great question from one of my
YouTube viewers Micheline who wrote in
to say hi ever my name is Micheline
Evans I really appreciate what you are
doing and saying you've really
encouraged me to step out up in my
business thank you so much for insight
and wisdom well thank you for commenting
I'm starting an advertising business for
small business owners and want to help
them go to another level people knowing
what products and service they render
now I started off on radio and magazines
I'm not getting a lot of customers
understand that I can help them I'm not
charging a lot of money for radio
advertisement I don't know what I'm
doing wrong could you please give me
some tips or ideas I would really much
appreciate it thank you so much you
can't wait to hear from you
so Micheline you're selling to
entrepreneurs you selling the small
business owners it's a really tough sell
because entrepreneurs we're tight with
our money right when we spend on an
advertising campaign it's not for
branding purposes we need to see a
result right here's an example so when I
read I work with brands I work with
companies I create a blog post for them
I'll help promote their content when I'm
working with a big brand I'll charge
them $2,500 to create one piece of
content a blog post to their site 2,500
bucks that's a lot of money if I tried
to sell that to an entrepreneur to pay
2500 you better get me some results on
that son because that's a lot of money
that's a big chunk of marketing for me
that needs to generate results so that's
the difference right like this has to
work if somebody spends money with you
that could be their entire advertising
budget for the year so it's got to work
there's a lot of fear so for you my
advice on how to sell radio or magazine
ads to small business owners one target
your market you have to know who you're
selling to right you've got to know the
right kind of people to sell to because
you're not going to sell that every
single entrepreneur and what I would
probably do is go look at competing
magazines look at competing radio
stations in different markets and see
who's advertising on their station what
kind of businesses are advertising there
and then go reach out to your local
market so I don't know where you are
let's say you're in New York I'll pull a
model like la find a similar magazine or
radio station that targets the LA market
and see what kinds of businesses right
you won't have the exact same
franchisor store here but similar kinds
of businesses is it a jeweler is it real
estate people is it you know
manufacturers who is it
that's advertising on the radio chances
are those same types of businesses will
be interested in your local markets you
have to really be specific because not
every person is going to be interested
you're not just targeting small business
owners you got to get a little bit more
niche the second thing is reduced the
risk you have to reduce the risk for
them and this goes for anything in sales
reduce the risk and make it easy to say
yes so I don't know how much it costs
for you to get started on this thing if
I wanted to sign up with you and take
out a radio ID what that cost me you'll
find a lot of business owners say this
is the catch-22 that you're in they'll
say I'm happy to spend on it if it works
right if I know that I spent a dollar
with you and I get five back I'm going
to do that all day long all day long but
I'm not guaranteed it's going to work
and I have you know I don't know
anything on radio or magazine
advertising most entrepreneurs won't
write that's what they'll say so there's
a huge risk so you have to find a
low-risk way to launch this thing you
have to find a way to for me to get it
either for free or to really reduce
price as my first time shot through once
you've qualified right you're picking
the right kinds of businesses that are
the right size at work base in other
markets and give them a low risk way to
get started because a radio station or
magazine once that air time where that
magazine goes out if they don't have the
sponsors in there it still has to go out
right that radio show is airing on this
day regardless if they have sponsors or
not so working with them to find deals
where you can start off small free
ideally or really super low-cost to get
them to try one time and sure that it
works if it doesn't work then they're
not going to continue right and then
that's that's on you because you pick
the wrong client the wrong campaign or
this station or this this magazine
doesn't work right you have to deliver
results when it does work then it's easy
to upsell them and get them to sign into
a full of campaign right so I sell I
sell zuga guides for entrepreneurs I
don't do advertising for I wouldn't go
out and take a magazine ad out or radio
show ad out right I wouldn't do that
it's not part of the model but if
somebody like you came to me
and here's a free way to do it as a
trial and it worked then I would start
spending money with you right if I can
show that hey I spent a thousand dollars
with miss Schilling she gives me five
back I'm going to do that no problem
let's let's ten times that let's keep
going right that's the that's the
catch-22 it's too risky for
entrepreneurs to get into they can't see
the proof they can't see the tangible
results or they're not going to do it so
you have to make it easy for them to say
yes the third thing is helping with the
creative a lot of entrepreneurs even if
they agree to it they don't know how to
make your radio ad they don't know how
to make a magazine ad so how can you
help them give them either tools
resources people a campaign something to
help them make that easy because I might
say yeah I love that but I don't what
does the radio spot sound like I don't
know how to do that so train them work
with them give them people to help them
so that that fear is gone you're you
eliminate all their objections right the
big two is going to be well I don't
think it's going to work it's too risky
for me and I don't have the resources to
make this campaign together you can
eliminate those you get people to say
yes but all is going to come from
targeting the right people you don't
know waste all this time and energy and
the you know the collateral you've built
with the stations your you know radio
stations of the magazines you don't
waste all that time only to have
somebody come through and then not sign
up right if you've delivered them
results and they don't sign up then you
need to do a better job qualifying
upfront make sure you get the right
people who can potentially afford this
thing when it takes off that's my advice
believe I love to hear what you guys
think if you guys have ever done an
advertising campaign with a magazine or
radio station leave it below let me know
what your fears are let me know what
worked what didn't work what you would
change you have other advice for
Micheline leave it in the comment
section below I really want to hear from
you you guys like this video thumbs up
below you want to see more like this
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon
you